a few times
few interviews and and one of the things
we've always brought up as Highlander um
so what's going on still fighting the
good fight um Highlander is an
interesting property it's through Lions
Gate as well and the owner it's we're
trying to get it done it's it's just I
mean anyone that knows anything about
the property knows it's got a lot of
meat to it it's a good property it's got
a lot of potential we're just trying to
figure out the best way honestly it just
not to [ __ ] it up just not to try and
fit it into an hour 45-minute movie and
not dead-end ourselves like
unfortunately the original series once
you come across with the overall pitch
of there can be only one and in your
first movie you kill everybody but the
one the sequels have a problem yeah sure
so we're trying to design it in a way
that gives us a bit of lead in a little
bit more chance to explore the mythology
and see some of the best care I mean
they did seven seasons of TV and even
though the TV show may not hold up today
the idea of it or the characters they
brought were super cool so we're trying
to come up with a methodology that
allows whether you want to call it a
pre-cool or something that leads up to
the quickening so we just don't end with
a one-on-one battle in you or cut off
the guy's head and that's it we want to
figure a way to do this right so it
becomes and I hate to use word franchise
but becomes more of a series whether
it's short for more long-form that would
let us explore that in the best way it's
like a look I I have a huge heart felt a
respect and love of the project and
we're just trying to find the best way
to do it that will give fans really what
they want so is it been determined
whether or not it could be a movie or a
series or it's still all being here we
have been it's still being fair that
we've already well past script phase
with a a feature-length version of what
we want to accomplish space that there
will be more after that because we want
to tell a story we want to tell the
complete story of the quickening the The
Immortals and all that stuff but uh you
know the overall entertainment medium is
changing so much
look what Netflix is doing look what you
know TV is doing now whether it's I mean
there as it as an action is any myself
there are like two or three episodes of
Game of Thrones that blow away 90% of
features that are work done
I mean it's just phenomenal what it's
doing Netflix has a whole new delivery
system we're features on that are coming
off differently am letting directors and
other filmmakers expand out safely
without being crushed with opening box
office so like there's a couple
different things we want to explore and
what is the best medium to bring this
out in and that's kind of where we're at
now
I completely understand what you're
thinking about I really hope it gets off
the ground saying I it's just such a
cool like we would love I mean there's
nothing I and there's all kinds of
fortunately projects that are open that
I'd be interested in but nothing more
than that